the idea of the authentic swing and  finding your authentic swing is the  equivalent of of your authentic self I  had two friends when I was a kid  identical twins who played golf and the  amazing thing to me was they had ABS  completely different golf swings and I  thought shouldn't they have the exact  same swing they're the same DNA  and it is true that in some crazy way  we're born with a swing and you cannot  change that swing if you think about  golfers like Fred Couples or Jim Furyk  that had these crazy loopy swings  they didn't they didn't evolve that  through study people will try to mold  themselves into some perfect kind of a  swing and it never works and the real  answer is if you can to find your own  authentic swing and then you know fine  tune it so I think that's the same thing  in in writing in art or anything in our  life is finding who who we are we  already are that thing if we can just  find it and be it